[Music]
well well well well well well howdy
hello hello how are y'all doing thank
you so much for joining me on this
wonderful day where we're gonna play a
wonderful game that got a wonderful
update called Bigfoot but before we get
into this I just want to say hi thank
you so much for being here thank you
much so much for being wonderful people
for this channel and thank you so much
for eagerly awaiting this livestream
that's coming at you right here and now
what the hell was that oh yay a slippery
videos donated 199 through super jab but
again I want to say right off the bat
you don't need to give me anything for
super tab that is absolutely not
necessary don't even worry about that
nothing no don't even don't even bother
with that stuff but thank you so much
for being here news update I've got a
lot of cool stuff in the works and
getting ready for PAX West which is
gonna be fun
and then just I've got some other cool
plans to get smaller sketch like stuff
coming at you faster and faster as soon
as I'm able to do that but I want to get
right into the game as soon as possible
I don't want to I want to be bogging it
down with anything like that so we're
gonna get into the game ASAP before I
get started though Thank You Dale sheep
Thank You Katherine hogs dad tatertot
mr. bloody shadows mastered ultra for
being part of the channel and thank you
for joining okay so with that being said
let me just make sure that's their
little little it okay are you ready
you're probably not ready probably not
because this [ __ ] is intense maybe I
don't know if you remember Bigfoot I
played this a while back I played it and
basically it was a game where you were
trying to hunt down Bigfoot there was a
game earlier maybe made by the same
people we never really confirmed whether
it was or was not but maybe made by the
same people the the rake game the one
about like hunting down the rake Thank
You Miranda Creole Liam divani pop-tart
King animal productions talen Wagner
Scott Fox fluffy cats Ellie thank you
bests magical life say Otonashi Nellie
Kapler the Queen Beth thank you
everybody so much for supporting the
channel in whatever way you have I'm
gonna get going right now thank you so
much oh my gosh there's so many coming
in all at the same time thank you
oh jeez okay good golly that's so many
notifications that I I'm
find it I'll try to handle them all hey
on one second we're getting to it thank
you thank you thank you you don't need
to give anything to soos don't don't
don't give me anything don't give me
anything like if anything become a
member so that I can give you stuff back
I've been giving stuff pretty regularly
to members and it's been super fun to be
able to interact with people like that
if you want a lot of perks like that you
don't need to give me money through
super chat just become a member and that
will give you access to a lot of really
cool things okay so enough of that
enough that we're gonna get into the
game here all right Thank You Ltd Kylie
and Fei McGee all right so this one is
Bigfoot the updated version now in this
game let me just go ahead and delete
that one I was just testing it to see
about getting in here this one we're
gonna call um blump blump fur give is
plumper dink okay doesn't really matter
so you get to pick which character you
want to be I think like the other one or
maybe you just randomly joined in as any
of them I don't even know so we're gonna
join in as this guy here and you can now
only go to Glacier Bay so this is
different from the other one because
you're not in the forest anymore you're
in a forest where you are snow and
that's important Thank You Kylie's [ __ ]
subscriber fat gap thank you so much for
that oh hi bye see ya I'll be here alone
in the woods he's no one around me
um okay
I didn't exceed I hear footstep mind I
hear footsteps when I loaded up this
game before there weren't footsteps so I
didn't go anywhere but I did bust out my
trusty rifle which I need to load up and
the flare gun which I need to load up as
well now this game is probably supposed
to be played with more than one people
and if you guys want I'll gather the
guys and we'll get a game going together
with the four of us trying to play this
Thank You wolfy babe thank you so much
for that thank you
Trin Rexy teal tubby Bailey green Clorox
bleach bar Thomas gin Colby cats kawaii
[ __ ] Wolfie gaming Thank You chrono
shadow master Paula ninety-eight lady
lupa Cassandra cardi Kayla Valentin
Amanda whis and everybody else that has
supported the channel alright we're
gonna get into this so the other dynamic
in this one that I noticed at the bottom
left you've actually got a temperature
gauge and the bottom right you've got a
body temperature gauge as you can see
I'm getting colder and colder which I
can only assume means that I need to get
some warmth in me and it's also the
sun's going down so they also give you a
much better map here that shows specific
locations wait a minute okay no it's not
the same I thought this maybe was the
same as the other one for a second there
but I'm assuming it's not so I'm gonna
head towards this abandoned research
base and officially we've gotten into
the area where I don't know what we're
doing oh I thought I saw the Yeti over
there okay and it's instead of Bigfoot
it's now the Yeti I mean I guess
technically it's the same thing right
ones just winter ones just in the woods
not winter yeah either way we're gonna
go find him we're gonna go hunting down
and I'm probably not gonna survive
but I won't know that until I try right
because if I remember last time it took
like the coordinated efforts of all of
us trapping him bugging him out above
the the place there oh okay flashlight
and then whaling on him with every
single bullet that we ever had which
probably isn't the best way to go about
things but that's a way that we're gonna
go
things you think that running would give
my body temperature up but apparently
not alright hello should be near it
should be able to see it at least hello
I like the way the sun's getting all
blood-red when it's going down the
horizon like that so the other part
about this game is that it requires
quite a bit of patience you know you
know in all other games usually I'm not
the most patient type of this one I'm
gonna try to be I should be right on top
of his base where oh there it is okay so
I think this is where I'm gonna get all
my supplies Oh door Oh door with big
window that seems like a very very bad
thing flare gun bullet they're gonna
bullet some kind of spoon
totally fine absolutely fine
oh okay traps is what I need when he
traps tents oh hell yeah I can actually
go tent out in the woods ooh a bat if
that log good that bats gonna do me okay
cameras so I need to put down cameras
because he what's wrong what's wrong I
keep thinking I'm hearing things out
there okay so if I was a big bubble
blowing [ __ ] baby I wouldn't go out
into the woods at night but I'm I'm not
that so I'm gonna go out into the woods
at night I'm gonna try to get this under
way so I don't know all the buttons
either so I don't know how to access
anything see VF is flashlight Q ah there
we go
okay night-vision camera one tablet none
maybe I can't even use the drone till I
get a tablet oh I love the Rumbo tombola
Bumby it's a lot of firewood here could
make a fire over here big fire mister
footy big Billy show your big old feet
over here there's a lot of people on the
internet it wants to see him okay so let
me try the drone I don't know if he's
gonna work okay hmm
droning no worky okay I don't think I
have the tablet so I don't think I'm
gonna be able to do that I don't think
that was a tablet in here
oh that's probably fine hey that's
probably fine
that's probably hundred percent fine
probably nothing weird about that in any
way shape or form rifle bullet box and
an axe no tablet that I can see another
trap down there it sure sounds like
there's something moving on the woods
over there okay so I'm gonna be a big
brave boy and I'm gonna go out into the
woods we're gonna try to make a camp
somewhere it's like every shadow is
probably the Yeti okay so the lakes
probably frozen over boo okay that's a
bush that's a Boosh so it's probably not
the best idea to go over there and
liking the other one there's probably a
lot of secret areas that need to be seen
all over the place oh thank you
Tyson TNT a [ __ ] each an Bend the hero
red Lac Kay Rudy thank you so much for
becoming members of the channel go check
out the community page if you want to
see some cool stuff that you have access
to all of a sudden Keira Robbins thanks
so much
fine
see the chances of me running into the
Yeti are very low cuz of just the size
of the map but that doesn't make me any
happier about it let me let me they must
have just programmed in random noises to
happen at any any moment cuz otherwise
this would be very bad okay here's a big
opening so I could put a camera right
here in the opening oh wait this is the
lake it's like a lake or something okay
this is a lake I don't really
necessarily need to see the lake but it
is kind of an opening it's kind of nice
maybe I would see something maybe kind
of pointed this way at least this just
got some visibility to it so maybe I
mean I'm not the best at camera
placement for this stuff so I don't
really know anything all right let's put
a camera here put one ride donk
today there we go hold it down okay
camera cool I still don't have a tablet
but that's just gonna be what it is can
you stop doing that
all right let's go try to find another
landmark of some kind cuz I know there's
got to be there was other bases that
were abandoned in the other place he's
got to be certain some places with some
useful tools cuz that I know that thirty
bullets isn't gonna be enough to be able
to get through all this but it'll be
enough for now
okay I'm assuming that's all fine again
it's not this it's not my favorite
assumption to make but it's the only
assumption I can make at this point
where I'm surrounded by death
literally avalanches of death coming
careening down in front of my face okay
this looks like a good vantage point I'm
gonna put another camera right right
here
good good vantage point good good
vantage but your work right here I can't
put it on a rock really no I can't put
it on a rock Wow okay I'll put it right
here then not as good a vantage point
but whatever okay that'll do moving on
okay this is higher up the mountain I
doubt that he'd ever come up here
okay Oh what the hell what did i do my
jaw got it my habit of just jumping
randomly and sporadically isn't gonna
work out over here so I guess I can do
that
man there could be something right in
front of my face and I wouldn't ever be
able to see it maybe going out in the
middle of the night wasn't the best idea
I've ever had but then again what else
am I gonna do okay maybe this would be a
good now I've got too many cameras right
next to each other I got to really go
out a distance I kind of want to see the
perimeter of the entire map before I
start going inwards again I'm gonna comb
it all serpentine style but before I can
do anything I got a got to get a lay of
land okay I mean there's a lot of land
that I can traverse I mean this map is
really huge kind of advantageous to have
more than one paper per pair per person
more than one people with you out here
in the middle of nothing alas I fear
that I may die scared it alone never
having enjoyed all the other better
right okay how about this I don't want
to go see the Yeti just yet
so I'm not gonna go towards that noise
of no no no no no no no come back
no come back okay all right I will what
would happen if I went out of bounds
was this a call how come why there's
such a tiny fall wasn't a little baby
fall oh no an old old old old a little
okay so I can't go that way huh
so this is kind of [ __ ] okay so the
map may not be as big as I think it is
but that doesn't mean that I ain't gonna
die a horrible horrible horrible death
in fact it may be more likely than come
back no no no no no okay I will do okay
so the lay of the land is really
funneling me into a narrow zone in
between here that's okay cuz now I'm in
a different segment I'm in the peninsula
this is kind of an open area but just
not very very visible but if I if I
point this inwards I might be able to
see something here so I'm gonna put
another camera right here right here
right there okay
pseudo I can see those but you know I
got him at least once I find whatever
the hell I'm looking for maybe I'll have
a better shot at this moon can you go
down cuz I know that's how day and night
works from Minecraft I know my intense
gamer skills tell me that it's true
I just got like this heart attack that
there was other footprints besides mine
in the snow yeah thank you death Hawks
Tiffany Stevens Hunter lamb Marley pop
Joby Michael Cruise Christopher Gantt
try sir Dark Prince Wren Didion yeah so
much for being members of the channel
check out youtube.com slash mark blessed
community for all the perks
Oh
what
I heard a biggle I heard a big ol thumpy
thump and it looks just like blood
spilling out from the trees but I think
that's the Sun coming up I heard a
distinct really heavy thumpy thump not
just a little thumpy thump with a map
even the map shows where the light is
that's cool that's really cool okay
I heard the distinct heavy footfalls of
a Bigfoot Oh like that but least day is
coming and I'll be able to see something
if I missed like a base or anything
because I couldn't see it at night I'm
gonna be very upset I mean not that
upset it ah no more upset than I am at
myself for just falling I think I did
that in the other game too the one where
you're fun not in the middle of the
winter I could just broke every bone in
my body
thank you hey dude hey Mark I love you
dude thank you dude thanks dude thank
you I'm in the middle of a pickle but
thank you thank you for that I'm gonna
put another one up on the top of this
hill here should be able to get a good
vantage point around the area Yeah right
about here it's a good spot donk
okay what's over the crest of this Ridge
here anything worth looking for no it's
gotta be something of the Tippie of this
Peninsula right I mean the cabin even if
it was marked on my map was hard to find
but I gotta imagine there's gonna be
something over here oh god I'm gonna die
just from my own stupidity god that's
never happened before in the history of
me playing video games has it never in
the history of ever
how's the game going I'm just getting
started we're just getting into it we're
getting into the nitty-gritty of this
and by that I mean we're just planning
cameras and pretending like it's
actually doing something making me feel
better at least at least I don't have
any stamin or anything my body
temperature is getting kind of low
that's probably a problem I should
probably address that it's making my
bones awfully brittle yeah someone
sneezed on my leg and his shoes
shattered the bone nothing over here
nothing up here Oh God
so the sheer drop oh that's probably
death
I probably spells a lot of death and
nothing of it then maybe maybe if this
is like a real thing here maybe maybe
the map can kind of showcase some of the
landscape that I should see okay this is
all just mountain here so I bet there's
probably only one thing that's hidden
deep in there but I'd never find it
there's got to be something up here
because this seems more like the plains
right here so I'm gonna I'm gonna head
away from climbing up these mountains
like an idiot because I know that it'll
only lead to me falling down like an
even bigger idiot and I don't think I
have any I have some meat so I could lay
a trap down but again I don't know what
the good that'll do when I've got a got
about 2,000 pounds of Bigfoot barreling
down my way maybe there's like a cave
system I know the other one I have like
a cave thing going on
this game update came out maybe like a
couple weeks ago for anyone wondering so
I don't know whoa hey hey hey hey I
don't know how many secrets have been
found maybe some maybe not a lot maybe a
lot okay well there's a bridge here I
don't like to look at the bridge but I'm
gonna go on the bridge why would
somebody put a bridge up here when you
could just go around it as easily as I
did but that leads to a valley somewhere
so that might be something yeah this is
the only sign of civilization here but I
have a funny feeling that's not actually
gonna lead to anything
nothing just a big nothing it's just a
big nothing Oh even if there is a
Bigfoot up here that's got to be like
the juxtaposition of all this you don't
know if there's a Yeti in these woods
but yet when you find it you know you're
gonna tell anybody my mind my legs are
being used to to clean out my ears like
cotton swabs anybody down there worth
going probably not okay I'm down that
lesson half health because I'm just dumb
put a camera on the bridge if it might
be a good idea but then again I don't
even know if I'd be able to put it in
the ground here because it seems to be a
requirement that it needs to not go and
rock I don't even know if I could make
it on the bridge before I do anything
else let me just find out let me get a
lay of the land I'm still getting a lay
in the land everybody's so eager and I
got to get a lay of the land first and
then I'm gonna lay a trap near my base
because if I can't find any more ammo
I'm just gonna be screwed but I can't
find anything else then well this is
gonna be mono e mono me and the man the
Yeti I mean the Yeti don't get along too
well so it's just gonna be mono e mono
of us screaming at each other as I run
away and it screams oh you shot whoo
dear I need you I need you for me can I
meet you up hey come on hey don't be shy
I'm just a crazed hunter looking for
some feet you got any feet no oh we're
to go really bolt that didn't it
well come on let me up here up top there
we go
no nope um no people nobody nope damn it
I could've used a meat alright next time
I shouldn't barrel so haphazardly
through the woods maybe I should be a
bit more cognizant of what's in my
surrounding area before I go slamming my
way through the underbrush oh part whoa
run the heart got it alright thank you
cool Oh oh my god oh very just died
terribly skid that is just the this is a
weirdest thing I've ever seen okay
Hackett II oh alright I'm missing but uh
and it's gone I'm very efficient very
efficient nothing goes to waste when I'm
hunting I thought I was gonna hurt my
legs again okay well that's good I got
some more meat how much more one more
meat really an entire deer broke down -
one more meat all right whatever okay
the least we're Megan's progress cuz
with that meat we're gonna be able to
lay more traps and I don't want to lay
any traps I mean you can trap him as
many times as you want or her I don't
know but he or she will only be
attracted to the trap if you put meat in
it so gotta give me some meat
I'm getting cold I'm gonna try to make
my way back to the home base and then
from there I'm gonna plan my next
maneuver I'm not sure if I want to trap
him right near the base
oh god that's such an idiot
I don't know if I want to trap him right
near the base or if I want to trap him a
little bit of ways there's been
something that says there was one of
these tips that was like Bigfoot's smart
Bigfoot no fall for same trick twice
Bigfoot gotta be like not go to trap in
same location so I don't know if that
means I got to move to a different
location once I trap them but I'm not
try yeah nothing
no Bigfoots yet no big feat here no big
fit no Bigfoot no Bigfoot I do love the
graphics so this place is awfully nice
sure does embrace the feeling of
loneliness that's coursing through my
body makes me feel like I truly have no
friends no matter which way I look no
matter what I do maybe I came out here
to run away from my problems and yet all
that surrounds me now with my problems
at least I have a good idea that there's
no Bigfoot just barreling towards me
right away
thank you to busy Sylvia Thank You Rosie
Tinsley Thank You Jessi cat
thank you what to do Joanna Guzman
Thiago Mori Sean Smith jr. where was
that something's going down
Suns getting real low buddy sounds
getting real low oh I'm getting real
cold ooh ouch ooch
ouchies whoo hey ouch
oh boo ah there's a crap oh no oh boy
well if I die maybe I've got no health
we've got no health I've got no health
this is the most harrowing thing what do
I know I'll get in the door going the
wrong way stupid or be by this Lantern
this is really gonna warm me up real
feel 21 degrees okay good at least
that's something
okay so I've gotten the layout sticks
why would I need sticks medicine here we
go Madison let me put some medicine in
me
that seemed like a suppository that
really that really seemed like a very
tubular shaped thing meant for making it
easier to shove up my own a noose why
why was that like that that that seemed
that seemed absolutely unnecessary I'm
not a hundred percent sure why that was
that all right whatever I I guess okay
sure Thank You T or ravening okay so
what am I do is I'm gonna go out in the
middle of the night and I'm gonna plant
a trap I'm gonna plant Oh Thank You
Junko Enoshima I love your vids mark
well thank you so much I'm gonna place a
trap down Kurt chunk I'm not gonna walk
into my own trap I'm gonna put meat on
the trap then I'm gonna wait right here
in the warmth of my own home or I can
see it and wait for a Bigfoot to stop on
by
any minute now there's going to be a
Bigfoot and that's gonna be good
get the axe for the sticks I couldn't
get the axe though he acts wouldn't why
can't see I can't see if there was a
Bigfoot there that's too dark Damon I
should have put a light or something out
there oh wait I see it okay
I think I'd see a Bigfoot I'm pretty
sure oh man the dynamic lighting of the
clouds and the moons pretty cool but I
think I'd see a Bigfoot if there was a
Bigfoot Prichard pushes somewhere
someway might see a Bigfoot thank you
Alicia
Thank You Xander Tod
maybe not maybe no no Bigfoot huh okay
so I've gone out this way I made this
big loop before I found a bridge and
nothing else so next time I'm gonna go
out
no it's still there it's still there
okay it's still there I think it's hard
to tell it's still there definitely
still there okay but I'm gonna go out
this way and try to make a loop around
here maybe go around this mountain if
it'll let me go that distance if Bigfoot
doesn't show up tonight which he might
he might still you never know what this
thing you know never know he might
I still don't know how to look up only
oh well oh I do have a tablet you can
use a fire or a room to keep warm if
necessary to mask the trap - Bigfoot
Bigfoot doesn't notice press the
interaction button Oh
Bigfoot reacts to both beep oh how do I
get out get out there we go still there
ok so I do have a tablet you zoom in
camera mode ok so let me look at my
camera's oh whoa ah okay I see this is
really terrible camera placement because
I can't see [ __ ] there so camera 2 is a
bust
camera 3 nothing camera 4
okay
was that just because wait was that was
that [ __ ] because on camera for did you
hear him is that what that was is that
here are in real life
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go put the
drone out we're gonna go take the drone
for a spin I'm gonna put the drone right
here plenty of space
okay plenty of space right here the
drone right there okay so there's the
drone I'm gonna take the drone for a
spin some good old night flying that's
what I like to do all right
tablet drone control whoa whoa whoa whoa
oh this awesome it's so cool oh this is
awesome
whoa okay doesn't really help me but it
would help me during the day to be able
to find Bigfoot and maybe if you had
four people playing you could have one
guy on the drone keeping track of them
like just getting a general idea while
everyone else kind of goes around oh I
can also just kind of spy where there
might be things that I need to go visit
this is cool yeah check the perimeter
ooh what is that it's not a Bigfoot no
it's a stick no it's a trunk it's a tree
this was letters tree corpse nah but
there's something out here oh oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
signals getting bad
Oh what is that what's that that's
nothing
snow literally snow it's a clearing I
can't see [ __ ] just because it is dark
out huh
okay but I'm gonna try this again when
it gets day so I'm gonna set her down
try to avoid losing some power set her
down
probably like right over here this isn't
really matter where I said it right
I don't think Bigfoot's gonna be curious
enough to just deal with this right okay
yeah
okay cool no Bigfoot still no Bigfoot
almost a no Bigfoot
well what the hell what the hell footy
big man why is it not good enough for
you oh maybe because I don't have leaves
or something
can I get leaves no those aren't leaves
is spindle ease well where can I get
some leaves I'm not gonna be able to get
leaves I'm not gonna be able to hide it
I know I need to hide it oh well oh well
that's not what I wanted okay put a trap
down maybe cover it cover it no I just
picks it up dammit how do I cover it
it's it it's it any instructions how to
do it and figure itself mask press the
interact button okay interact button
know if that picks it up how does that
do anything do anything give me some
leaves
give me some goddamn leaves but what am
I gonna do to get some goddamn leaves
just let me put some leaves on this bad
boy please please let me put some leaves
on this bad boy anybody and whatever
fine oh wait do I need to go get leaves
sticks no okay never mind
I have no idea what I need to do I'm
just gonna leave this meat right there
that's gonna be that okay can't be long
until day now
and no sign of the big foot thick foot
no sign of thick foot I don't think how
are you doing whatever you say man
whatever you say thank you cylinder guy
56 happy birthday to Sara Mortimer well
happy birthday Sarah Mortimer the only
other thing that I can think that I
could do right now would be to try to
fly the drone some more but again I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to see
anything I guess I just got to get real
low then that's gonna be the case I'm
flying this way gotta do some like super
awesome very radical tree dodging of
some sort no no hello hello eyes danger
eyes a bad idea
hello anybody here hello hello hello
hello and they body whoa crevasse that
lead to anything cool no it's a bridge a
bridge thing I think this is where the
force awakens was filmed anything over
here hello oh it's like I'm on Endor
yeah oh okay
ow it's fine yeah it's fine
real dark stupid night making it all
dark and [ __ ] what the hell it's so dark
now also I hit something was it so dark
tones like this dense forest is blocking
out all the light
what is [ __ ] oh it's just some
[ __ ] I can't see anything
what's even the point
[Music]
nope nope can't see [ __ ] but at least
the moon's almost down right maybe I
don't know I don't know I can't see
anything all right well it's so dark I
cannot see Oh moon come back
what the hell Moon Moon what the hell I
can't see [ __ ] it's it's like
pitch-black now moon moving what the
hell oh I'm just gonna go down whoo
I hit something what did I hit whoa go
down down and a landing it counts I
guess oh I'm right by where I needed to
be okay well that's nice
well that's nice okay so we weren't very
successful in terms of finding big
um okay
I thought I could've sworn I heard him
and some steppy Stumpy's but apparently
not so that's good okay alright anyway
there's my drone and now the sun's
coming up so I can take the drone out
again without crashing and hopefully
without crashing it and I can try to
scout out some good locations but first
I want to see just just how did how damn
handsome am i oh my god I'm gonna chop
my head off here oh look at me you can't
even tell hello hello hello okay
whatever
alright so we're gonna take this thing
out oh whoa whoa I take this thing out
where we going this way okay let's see
if we can find something now we should
be able to find something I would
imagine anyway cuz there's got to be
more stuff here and I can definitely
cover more ground with this thing that I
can on foot no no no it's a rock more
rock more rock I mean I could just look
up online see where the map is if
someone's made a map of all the
interesting locations here it's fine
everything's fine it didn't hurt no oh
cave no waterfall what's at the top of
the waterfall anything nothing nothing
up here
nice little crisscross a little tree
thing going on at the end I mean that's
nice and all but why nothing what is
that oh never mind that's not where I'm
supposed to be I'm sure that's like the
the barrier of being like don't go that
far
don't go there don't go it's bad for you
that's real bad
[ __ ] I [ __ ] it I [ __ ] it I [ __ ] it
and I [ __ ] it
look look look guys hey whoa easy up
there it's fine it's totally fine I
meant to do that it's all good
don't worry about it it's fine I'm fine
totally intentional I'm gonna look up um
I'm gonna look up see if anybody else
has made like a map of it cuz I'm not
above cheating but you never know okay
full map here we go ah here we go okay
so someone's made a full map of the
various different things on here okay
that's good
okay so there's apparently one right
here so if I go directly north and go
this way there's apparently something
right there some kind of a a cabin or
whatever have you straight up here
almost like a bullet straight north of
where I was I bet if I go swimming
around in the row and the river it's
gonna be very bad for me body temp wise
right
Yeah right right it should be dead in
front of me I think anyway hello this is
where it says it should be
oh wait a little east of here hey hey
hey there we go not what I was expecting
oh well that's awfully noisy for me
finding this at least you got more
bullets
alright found that what's next okay
there's some kind of a camp an old camp
like right about here so let's go
towards that one all right
making progress play the old making some
serious progress progress making some
progress
don't break my legs okay thank you right
about right about up this way
some kind of campfire probably but
probably nothing good there but it's the
closest landmark after that one and then
there's a cave up north and everybody
knows that caves are super fun this so
why not right yeah why not I should be
dead ahead
don't I'll leap of faith' yeah no I got
it I know what I'm doing I'm pretty good
at this game I'm pretty skilled at
pretty much everything I do I'm pretty
much the best all right so it should be
right around here somewhere like right
in front of me there's something here
right around here you're dead ahead I
don't know how I'd be able to find this
without this guide and you Joe here man
you would just have to stumble across
that oh holy crap tourist camp you whose
touristing out here who is this like the
Russian pass incident what was the name
of that that thing where the the people
just ran out of their tents on
inexplicably and they just couldn't stop
super bizarre there's another trap okay
did I get everything I needed I got more
traps that's good all right but it
didn't help me in terms of heat okay so
I'm gonna go up to this cave was
apparently a cave up north here right
about where my drone started losing
signal that's where I gotta go all right
something up north right at the head of
that river so I got to go to the river
and then I got to follow it north and
hopefully I can find a way to get myself
warmed up because otherwise I'm gonna be
trapped out in the wilderness it's only
getting colder and colder and I'm gonna
die this storm it's actually kind of
cool that there's a weather system
implemented Omega one way to go
yeah the dill atop a sin Siddhant yeah
that one if you've never heard of that
one that one's a fascinating story
there's been a number of podcasts that
have done stories about it that do it in
really dramatic fashion and I think it
can only be told in really dramatic
fashion because the whole incident is
just so bizarre and inexplicable that
the only way that you can talk about is
with people that just have no idea
what's going on but ideas of what
happened because this is such a bizarre
thing these campers were out there
experienced skiers I thought that was an
animal experience skiers and whatnot
that just were camping up a storm rolled
in and then they all fled their camps
they liked or their way out of their
tents it made no sense no sense at all
and there's like different explanations
like Yeti aliens this weird sound
tornado thing that somebody was talking
about like it's it's so bizarre whoo oh
so there is a cave at the end of this
right oh yeah yeah this is some weird
like land formation here I don't know
what's going on here this is where the
Yeti makes its home this is where the
Yeti makes his babies Yeti babies oh
there we go oh this would have been
tucked away here Oh a nice rib cage oh
no is this where Luke Skywalker was
taken oh all right oh boy oh boy okay
did I get that okay well good news
that's not a human skull so that that's
good that's that looks more like a
Bigfoot skull rifle Lantern here we go
lantern I don't think it's gonna make me
any warmer and oh it's like Captain him
that's Captain America's shield why I
mean it makes sense it was Thor's hammer
and the other one but here's Captain
America's shield are you suggesting that
this is Captain America oh yeah is that
what you're suggesting here the Captain
America or maybe Captain America was
here and he had to eat a Yeti to try to
survive and I think that's the only
explanation here but Captain America
okay all right makes sense to me again
okay so what I'm gonna do yeah I'm gonna
head back out I don't have much time
there's another cave right near here
maybe it's got more supplies maybe
something with which to heat me up I
don't know
now we're gonna be trapped out of the
night okay good thing I didn't fall in
the river okay
it's way up these mountains okay I think
it's way way way up these mountains it's
amazing that I've been playing this game
for as long as I have already and no
sign of mr. Yeti man where's the yet
come on where's the yet where's the
world where's the big ole yet man now I
can't go up this sheer cliff here I
gotta go around a little bit find a way
up whoa
all right okay nothing there yeah it's
way way way up there
and I just got to find my way up gonna
be hard to do when I can't see [ __ ] no
I'm not that way maybe that way oh yeah
that way okay
Oh what
what was that everybody saw that right
I'm not crazy
it's all light out of the corner of my
eye okay Hey well it's so dark why the
moon gotta be goin moon are you gonna be
gone okay it's that's hard to tell but I
think it's still North but pretty much
where I'm headed
I can't climb that nope break my ankles
oh I'm fine I'm fine
shrug it off I thought I was dead I
thought I was dead a hundred percent Oh
apparently not yeah shrine Ava's fine
whatever a few broken ankles was new I
just get a new one it's all good so
goddamn tough so [ __ ] amazingly tough
nothing can hurt me sneeze it away this
blow my nose this Bo's much pain you
caused me yeah all right anyway not do
that again
come on please please pretty please I
know I can get up here come on oh you're
right there
oh come on you're right there right
there oh come on come on please
oh [ __ ] okay shoot jerk okay that's no
organ there's gotta be another way up
right here we go here we go here we go
no oh come on mice it's got to be so
hard what cause secret would be up here
maybe there's like an actual easy way to
go up here and I'm just taking the
stupidly difficult way I didn't work
okay let me go around one more maybe
there's another path or something why
did that hurt
I didn't even go down I wasn't even
headed downwards
I didn't even jump oh okay ah okay here
we go everywhere how's it better
okay up a little more where am I in
terms of Oh goddamnit I'm wait I'm still
nowhere near I just gotta keep going up
oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh okay maybe
not that way come on come on go yes
there we go I feel like I'm climbing
mountains in Skyrim I alwa why didn't
even fall oh and they're armed dead okay
what the hell oh oh well maybe another
time well screw you maybe another time
what the hell all right well you use you
sack of [ __ ] I'm going back in same old
slump or dink same ol me same old slump
or dank you get you no no it's fine no
it's no big deal it's nothing at all no
nothing to nobody
where am I now why am i over here oh we
didn't even save the other cave Oh screw
that [ __ ] down I'm gonna go over this
way I'm gonna go this other one there's
something over here on top of this
mountain
well that's a bunch of ball sack
[ __ ] five or so on that's so dumb
I'm not dead
mrs. same old me I'm fine look at me you
see you see a problem here no I'm fine
everything's fine especially me what's a
stupid bull that's what that is okay I'm
gonna put a camera here come on get down
to business here too busy dealing with
crap I shouldn't deal with trap there
I'll put some meat on that trap there we
go that good got my gun go go find this
other thing
a slump or dink a relative of mum Fleur
functor dink I'd like to think so
I'd like to think it after going to west
of loathing you know going through the
old Wild West decided to go hunt some
Bigfoot but you know a few generations
down a few marriages you know last name
kind of changed a few times right is
that Sun going down is that Sun coming
up I bet it's going down on my luck and
knowing where the save last should be on
it sits on top of another mountain would
what whoa whoa whoa whoa hey whoa whoa
hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
Wow
okay
mr. Thunder toots decided to pay me a
visit
all right well that was our first
encounter didn't expect that to happen
but uh happened it did so happen it did
all right
listen listen man I'm just trying to get
by don't mean you no harm
I just want your sweet delicious
delectable feet ah oh that didn't hurt
me for some reason why why can't I get
up this mine
come on I was in the invisible wall how
it is huh it's stupid stupid stupid all
right how do I get up here then okay
there's got to be an easy way to get up
these mountains but I'm not finding it
cuz I don't know I'm dumb I guess well
maybe I found it maybe this is it maybe
the path that doesn't look like it's
going straight up at a 90-degree angle
is the way that I'm supposed to go oh
well that doesn't make no sense I don't
believe that for a single minute no way
no and why do I keep going back to the
meat all right it should be up here more
to the south little Southie here okay
okay and Sun just went bye-bye in two
chunks son go bye-bye but it should be
it south of here I don't like the way
the light flickers when he's nearby too
cuz if I couldn't tell by the thunderous
feet falls I guess you know maybe I
should upgrade my observational skills
okay should be right here she'll be
right here or maybe I pad up is that it
ah there it is there it is okay and the
tower three found good uh what is that
just a flare is that really it really a
flare one flare that's all I get well
that's stupid
well that's dumb well that's so dumb
where's dead stupid alright whatever I'm
gonna put a camera here I guess
yeah it's gonna be my last camera try to
put it like the top of the crest of
something or other right here put
another trap right chair and meet it up
okay I don't know how to get any leaves
because these trees don't look like they
have leaves okay so there's a few other
places over in the other woo what did I
just hid over in the other area oh my
head towards those try to get the last
of the supplies and then it's gonna be
al why that wasn't even far it wasn't
even a far drop his games a little
inconsistent on his fall damage here
well [ __ ] if you ask me
alright so it should be down this way
look that would have been bad that would
have been bad good thing I didn't do
that oh good thing I'm trying to fall
down a sheer cliff but this is gonna end
badly fine it's fine we're fine
everything's fine everything's fine you
know I've not died to the Yeti I've only
died to my own stupidity how many times
have I said I was gonna do that
yeah that's pretty much all it is
okay we're fine
ah here yeah this away right right
towards ya this way okay
straight this way will be the next thing
straight this way yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah hey yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
you sticks for fire I don't even know
where to get sticks so I just pick him
up by Wacom WAP them with my knife how
do I get sticks I don't even know how
how to get six
oh they're some sticks on the ground or
stick sticks ah ah
the vast majority of sticks are actually
sticks
I gotcha oh I see well I'm gonna need
that because I'm gonna get Coulier
pretty soon that it's gonna be another
it's gonna be another kind of like thing
up ahead I think it's a hunting Tower
I'm not a hard Accenture but I think
it's a haunting tower and hopefully oh
wait I got medicine let me let me shove
this on my ass real quick there we go I
feel a lot better okay I got that and
when we go find one I need to find tower
right should be bro uh okay everything's
fine
right over here right I should be
looking right at it it should be right
here right here right here baby
it's right here here's where I am here's
where it should be
I don't know it find me up here here's
hello no no I it's here
aw no it's alright just here yeah over
here should be right here is it under me
it might be underneath this like over
look here but no it's just no right here
no nothing in here no tell it says I'm
right on top of no behind me now okay
well this is inconsistent in weird
okay so right it should be right here it
says it's right here right here
somewhere
it's supposed to be right here I swear
waita lion-o Dalai oh there it is oh god
I must have been right on did you guys
see it oh you guys saw it oh you guys
saw it oh alright well god it's not
giving me anything besides his hunting
materials so I guess it's just time to
go mano a mano with the the Bigfoot I
guess yeah alright let's see if we can
take this this footy man down Oh 40 man
forty man put him in put him in put him
in put him in the trap
put him in come at me come at me foot
man oh where are you where are you get
tripped I put a trap I put a trap I put
a trap foot man put me on footie footy
man man man of foot I put a trap down
what the hell foot man oh jeez
stupid a hole I'll take my trap back big
old douche waiting you oh I just don't
like the way you sail off a mountain
sometimes points sometimes all right
what a foot man okay actually there's
one more thing there's a medicine and
then there's something that looks
different than all the other places so
I'm gonna head towards that I'm gonna
need to set up a camp eventually here
but foot man's probably in the vicinity
and foot man's is waiting for me to make
a mistake thank you fun with Christina T
dizzle Samuel does vlogs Mercedes
raghu's Katie Atkinson dong gooks little
[ __ ] roadkill stolen gold Natalie
Hoffman bola gravy
thank you guys so much for supporting
the channel yeah yeah whatever you can
mask the traps by holding E oh that
makes sense
oh that makes a lot of sense okay
holding E right of course okay
holding a write of course why wouldn't
it just make it automatic why do I do it
what would I have to do that why do I
have to go the extra step please just
just sort out the people that are stupid
like me
oh here's the moon hidden away behind a
mountain oh that's dumb
oh god I'm an idiot I knew it was
something to do with E but hold down E
so it should be somewhere here tucked
inside these mountains here I don't know
where Thank You animal lover 500 I don't
know where it is somewhere down here up
in here in the nooks and crannies of
this right in the crevice of this place
okay getting real close but I don't know
if it's gonna be high up or what
I guess the only way to go forward is up
so this must be like generally where
it's gonna be
geez no this is spells death for me the
temp oh no come on
oh come on climb that it's snow come on
oh you've got to be kidding me
better not get me stuck down here oh you
bet all u s-- piece of [ __ ] do not okay
there we go
huh all right where are we going we're
close we're very close we're very close
I think I don't know man whoa Oh mystic
stones that's what I came here for
I gotta make a 10 now okay tent it up
get quick get in the tent
I'm trying where's the entrance to okay
there it is okay how do I crouch how do
i how do I crouch how do i how do I get
in the I don't know don't tell you just
tear the tendon F no open the tent damn
it open up there we go
I'm gonna get into how do okay
I'm too tall I've never run into this
problem I'm too tall what the hell I'm
too tall guys what campfire there we go
all right there we go
ah that's nice all right now we're in
the mystic stones I guess I guess we are
what do we do with the mystic stones
here what are the mystic stones all
about oh there we go okay all right
mystic stones mystic bones mystic bones
mystic stones what am i doing but hey
you want some of this huh what yeah baby
boy want some huh huh baby boy baby boy
big boy bigfooty boy wants to wants to
dance huh well I got Wow well I'll get
shot get Chuck BAM oh not today not ow
oh you sack of tit Oh get your Oh missed
well I think it's clear who won that
battle huh
where you going we're going footing it
boink yeah you better run away from me
when you think you can get me huh
you give me foot man huh that's what I
thought that's what I thought that's
what I suspected all along bigfooty
footy man's coward 30-foot man's a big
old coward can't take me on in a proper
fight yeah well there's got to be
running hit-and-run style I don't play
by that rule I'm gonna die from a fall
damage I don't play by those rules I
play by my rules my big strong manly
rules unlike a certain footy man where's
it there's a cave somewhere right here
not ours I'm sure but it should be like
right in front of me is it underneath me
what's the deal here
it's supposed to be supposed to be dead
ahead of here on Harper sent sure
no that's where I fell in before where's
this cave it says it's supposed to be a
cave here where's this goddamn cave is
it actually actually nothing I'm looking
at it looks like it's right where I set
my trap okay
that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] and it's [ __ ] I'm going
back in we're getting rid of slump for
dink we're bringing in the the the
40-foot a fetish
feisty foot feisty footy fetish man
that's me oh yeah me oh that's me
you know who's feisty fetish foot man
William oh yeah you know he is oh yeah
oh we're coming for you big-time
well I'm coming for you big-time cuz I
now I know how to play this game even
though I probably should have realized I
knew how to play this game before from
the last time I played this game before
I was up there but now I really know how
to play this game whoo I'm gonna get my
drone back whoo I'm gonna I'm gonna be
all up in those feet oh I'm gonna just
be sucking on each one of those
Tootsie's you can't hide them from me no
no no you think you can but you cannot
oh no there's no hiding those sweet
succulent Tootsie's from me
whoo I'm gonna get you good and you
think you you think that you're not
gonna be God but I'm gonna get you so
good mmm
yeah you you you it's like it's not me
trapped on this island with you it's you
trapped in this island with me and whoo
oh boy I am the Thunder and you are
gonna get a whirlwind to hurt once I
find you and chop off your touch see
what season whoa I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go ring around the rosies all over your
toesies you know what I mean yeah I'm
coming for you I'm coming for you hot
heavy and hard oh you don't even want to
rue the day that you thought that you
could deal with bumper dink when you got
me up in here
mr. footy fetish man well if I Steve
foot
I'm good you
[Music]
I get you boink raccoon oh yeah oh yeah
yeah choppity choppity chop got some
meat mmm not really good for the
touchies but good for the meat the trap
you de Tootsie's you want to know why we
only got bear traps cuz they're traps
those sweet succulent OG would seize all
in a sweet grab you're never gonna get
that foot back you have to chew it off
alright ok it's fine we're gonna get
back into this it's gonna be fine
everything's happy everything's good
everything's fine then turn on cameras
got ok got those got this got this flare
guns good gonna bat okay good
got the trap good that's the drone got
the rifle bullets got these got that got
a tent we're good to go
another Lantern turn it on double light
it wasn't lanterns here before were they
I guess items are randomly generated but
it doesn't matter cuz tonight's night I
got a date alright so I'm gonna lay a
trap right out here well well well well
down you go
can I swim apparently apparently I can
swim real good my body temperature don't
even go down oh I'm a badass
look at me I'm coming for you dear Thank
You Jonathan Potter and loved the
channel can't wait to oh why did it say
I miss it and went by so quick I'll get
it in just a second thank you so much
you still screaming you screaming I
scream you scream we all scream for ice
cream
okay whatever okay so that's actually
that's actually not a bad idea I'm gonna
put a I'm gonna put a trap out here on
the other side yeah that's what that
whoa apparently not okay never mind then
okay never mind then
I'm put it over on the shoreline over
here I guess can't put it on the ice for
some stupid reason okay but I'm gonna
put it right here on the shoreline right
here where I can see it holdy ahaha no
no no no one will ever know put the trap
bait the trap
okay go over to the other side and wait
wait oh so succulently with a gun right
hey hey can I climb this no I cannot
okay am I stuck
did I just kill myself somehow can I get
back up please
can I get up ELISA up ELISA please
can i up ELISA thank you okay so where
do the whys don't jump in the water okay
where's that trap I think it's right
over there right that's where it be
right did not put it there Oh
where'd I put the trap I don't even know
anymore I think it's over there I think
oh god damn it oh I'm such an idiot
oh such an idiot I didn't even remember
where I'm gonna put that it's gotta be
it's right there I know it's right there
why is an icon not showing up for it
okay whatever
if a Bigfoot e woody comes over that way
I'm gonna get him her okay
that's just one of many traps that I
have okay so I need to put another trap
let me write across this river like
right here yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
good trap right here plunky dunk and
then we're gonna put that there and then
meet it up nobody knows nobody knows oh
yeah
oh yeah I know where is he
alright I'm gonna go inside for a second
just to warm up
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make I'm
gonna plant a camera right here so that
I can always come back and I can always
see this is like the home base camera
that I can always know what's going on
in my home base but doesn't look like
he's being too friendly on the first
night his mistake not my mistake his
mistake but I I'm gonna go to the first
hunting tower what was that
oh did you get caught huh what was that
huh yeah yeah I'm coming for you here
you better be scared before you can I
closed myself in here no huh I'm coming
for you yeah oh I'm coming for you
oh I'm coming for you oh you think you
can run away from me no yes there is no
it's just no I got your number
I got your number now oh I got your
number I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get
you so good you're never gonna know that
you got got cuz in the amount of kidding
I'm gonna get to you your days are done
piggy footy boy there's a done foot man
Oh your days are done cuz markiplier is
in the woods with you and you don't know
where I am
cuz I've rubbed dirt and poop all over
my face no one can see me or smell me no
no I'm just making up on you I got I'm
going to the old hunting Tower
you know the hunting tower one where you
almost got got before by someone who
wasn't nearly as scaled or poop covers
me I'm coming to you oh yeah
another trap yes please yes you please
oh yes please II yes squeezie Polizzi
get you get you don't rub poop on my
face what are you talking about how am I
supposed to mask my smell ah
alright fell but I needed that just to
wake me up it's like my morning coffee
falling and snapping my shins like twigs
I'll get you I'll get you pretty footy
man
oh you foot man you ain't going see
nothing that's going to be 42 me oh you
got trapped Oh Oh mr. funny man got got
Oh No Oh stupid footy man Oh Oh No
you still there you better still be
there well I'm coming for you well I'm
coming for you where you go where you go
oh yeah BAM
oh you think you got got huh you ain't
got got enough hey BAM alright whoa hey
whoa whoa oh yeah that's right that's
right oh you kid no ow ow ow oh wow
but I got you oh I got him oh yeah I did
a number to him he did a number to me
but most of that me was done by myself
to me okay good okay but I got to take
more advantage of the traps okay so we
won't be trapped there again so I gotta
I gotta I gotta think of something else
I think of something else for that
someone traveling over here
I bet if I go over here Oh footy man
ain't no and no nothing to me for the
man ain't no nothing
I'm 40 man so stupid 40 man think that
I'm stupid footing man stupid funny man
big stupid 40 man never never seen a
stupid as big as I'm I'm not I'm not
stupid why I never be stupid you know
what else I'm gonna do for 40 man when
he comes barreling after me after I find
him he's gonna he's going run straight
into this one he's gonna run him one
after another mono he boom boom boom
done
he's gonna be done you never gonna see
me sweet succulent feet those sweet
savory succulent feet are gonna be all
over me like a necklace okay so he could
go to either these actually I guess
that's you could go to a
okay I think it's fine
shoot him in the deck I'm drunk I'm
gonna try I'm gonna try i'ma try welcome
Jessica Smith thank you so much
welcome phantom River I don't feel
wishbone Elizabeth lover us he could go
to the other one across the pond but I
don't want to risk missing out on this
cuz he's ran off this way so maybe this
is too close to the other one
okay I'm gonna look at my camera zoom it
across the pond right there --is--
all right I'm gonna leave these be I'm
gonna go find another one I'm gonna try
to go far away I'm gonna go towards
another hunting cabin maybe up on this
mountain I'm all place a trap up there I
got one more trap in one more meet
hopefully I can find more deer and to
get more meat from and hopefully I can
find more trap and more bullets to
because I'm definitely gonna need that
guys ever good god damn it now it's
gonna be another oh no it's gonna be
another one of these situations where I
can't find it up into this thing stupid
mountains why don't they make stairs on
these things I've also got to put traps
maybe maybe it would be a good idea to
put a trap on the bridge maybe that'd be
a good place to wait for him like on one
side of the bridge while he he gets a
trap on the other you know what I mean
then I can shoot from him I can shoot
him across the way I can put a trap
right on one either side I'm stuck okay
maybe that's a good idea that's that's a
really good idea of course it's a good
idea I came up with the idea therefore
it's a good idea I'm just a goddamn
genius come over here I'm practically
practically watching Rick and Morty I'm
so smart over here IQs over 3,000 okay
somewhere up here there's got to be a
goddamn way up dear god damn another
scared away a deer oh never mind did not
oh you moved what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you deer bastard oh come on
right as I go to shoot right as I shoot
right as I shoot right as I shoot ass
stupid
that's dumb what's dumb that's a whole
lot of dumb god damn it that's dumb
that's stupid and dumb alright it's fine
I'm just trying to get to this goddamn
hunt no no
no no no no okay
goddamn it I'm just trying to get to his
goddamn hunting cabin I had to go all
the way down to the south edge of the
freaking map somewhere up here okay
I want another piece of meat and I want
another trap I want to to catch him on
the bridge all so I can just kill a deer
and leave it there and that's gonna
that's gonna draw his attention to
because he's also attracted to just like
normal carcasses or she you know still
don't know which okay should be right
right over this it's right around here
right around here
flares flares flares
I don't need flares many bullets many
traps flares first ah goddamnit
okay well might as well flares so stupid
alright I gotta go find more stuff
that's gotta whoa okay almost died there
mama get him I'm gonna get him alright
oh I am gonna get him get him so good
I'm gonna go find the the camp cuz there
I can start a campfire anyway and just
get this stuff that was part of that cuz
I think there was a trap there last time
I'm not sure if there will be again but
maybe there'll be the other benefit of
my other game that I was playing where I
was slightly more stupid than I am here
that was an animal that was an animal I
was like a raccoon sound where is it
got okay but take this meat I don't know
if it's big enough for it to the guy
Devils come for okay so I got meat
that's good
wonder if there's a way that I could
like cook meat what about birds I hear
these birds all the time but I don't
know if they're actually real I haven't
ever seen one hmm worry about later
hey I hear another raccoon
the dog who's that
oh it's a fox okay cool
I hear a raccoon as well there is a
raccoon here there I saw that man I'm
gonna run out of bullets I'm gonna have
to go I would have to knife the Yeti to
death at this rate where'd it go
well I thought
thought I saw it did I see it no I
wasn't mistaken
and I think it's long gone bird bird
real you real bird probably not okay
whatever what
I hear it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa haha how about
no no dog God dog god damn it alright
fine dad are you gonna be trying to
chase down a goddamn raccoon you're
gonna come cheap shot me like that you
stupid stupid I hate you all right I'm
just gonna go find a stupid thing I'm
running low on traps so I gotta just use
if I if I find another trap up here I'm
just gonna use the I'm gonna use the
carcasses from the animals to try to
draw its attention after that that's all
I'm gonna do okay so it's somewhere way
WAY farther north okay get in there get
in there get in there
yeah it's gets terrifying when that Yeti
comes barreling out of nowhere
let me let me take my medicine when that
Yeti comes barreling out of nowhere
that's it's goddamn terrifying because
so sudden this is so out of nowhere it's
so it's so out of nowhere somewhere
should be dead ahead
what God should be here there it is okay
please have a trap please have a trap
yes
trap thank you okay I'm gonna use this
on the bridge I'm gonna make another
campfire there right there okay warm me
up okay anything else here of value no
nothing really nothing anything in here
nothing I can't crouch in here anyway so
what does it matter nothing
yeah nothing okay I guess this is gonna
be mono e mono so I gotta go find the
bridge but the bridge was all the way
over here so that's a long way away so
what I got to do maybe I can find an
animal out here and hopefully get some
kind of carcass trap going on otherwise
he's just gonna come for me cuz he ever
wanted to do that lately after I first
started wounding him seems like he wants
to come to me but I don't have enough I
don't have enough I don't have enough
bullets is the problem since when did
they add guns they've always had guns in
this game yeah how else were you gonna
kill Bigfoot howls are you gonna kill
him gotta get him somehow
we can't promise that these guns are
actually gonna kill him but I mean I
need more bullets so badly okay I'm
gonna go up to the since I'm near here
I'm gonna go up to that cave cuz I think
that had some good stuff lots of bullets
up there I'm gonna go up to the cave by
the mouth of the river that'll be at
least something keep me in the game long
enough that I'll actually stay alive
also next time he comes barreling at me
I might just try to I just try to run
away
play increase my chances of survival you
gon get him he been got bro oh I know he
been got look I know he been got I'm an
expert at this I'm an expert at getting
getting them and I'm gonna get them good
when I find him I'm gonna get him I'm
gonna squeeze him with my hands I'm
gonna get him
definitely gonna get him I'm definitely
not not gonna get him I'm gonna get him
good and he's gonna get got he's gonna
be like no don't got me in to be like
too late I got I get I'd you've been get
too late
and then he's got easy peasy
miss is somewhere in here hopefully
there's bullets maybe even another trap
if I'm lucky I also I'm gonna pick up
the ones by my base because I have a
funny feeling that that's too close
quote unquote to the previous one we've
got a lantern and bullets and medicine
that's helpful a flare that's unhelpful
because I got no one here to stand
beside me okay at least we got some more
bullets so with V
I heard that I heard that yeah I'm gonna
go pick up the ones that were near where
he was before and I'm gonna take those
and use him again because I think I
think I think a thunk oh I'm funcle' in
that this may look Hey
I'm Duncan I'm Duncan real good I'm
thunk going then maybe maybe it's too
close to where he got got and he doesn't
want to get got there so I'm gonna use
the bridge strategy I want to sweep
those up I'm gonna go go to the bridge
it's gonna be good I'm hearing a lot of
noises around me whoa no no no
no no or are you just messing with
mirrors is real right now
I'm I'm very confused but I knew it I
know it I knew it I knew it I knew it I
knew it I'm running I'm running come at
me could you think of me do you think
you can give me huh no yes no where are
you oh babe I got you in the dick I try
you in the dick don't think I didn't oh
okay
what the hell
ow what the [ __ ] what a follow-up shad
one cheap [ __ ] oh it's stupid
oh god I knew it that's so dumb it's so
dumb
what's so dumb it probably was prolonged
falter fall damage from me being hit off
the mountain was probably just delayed
like that
yeah whatever it's fine okay I haven't
done nearly as much damage as I want to
but it's all because of prep I got the
prep so I got what I need so I'm gonna
go pick up what I what I left behind I'm
gonna use that I'm gonna get them good
I'm gonna get them good guys if you
believe that I'll get them good uh
tickle the Tootsie's of the like button
I guess whatever the flares might scare
them away that's a good point that month
that actually I think I remember that
being a thing let me pop in here real
quick why did my light go flicker real
quick why did my light flicker my light
flickered
Oh rifle box I forgot about that okay
more bullets good my leg definitely
flickered there for a second so that's a
thing
okay whatever I'm gonna go get my other
thing I'm gonna go the bridge oh wait
did the meet how did he eat the meat off
of it how did he eat the meat off of it
but not get trapped oh that's so dumb
the meats gone Oh doh doh
all right fine whatever it's okay I'm
gonna do the bridge thing
I think well maybe if I even stand in
the middle of the bridge that might be a
good idea probably not actually now that
I say that it's probably not a good idea
but I think there might be a good idea
if I to stay in the middle of it it'll
be all good yeah what could go wrong
then if he comes from either thought
other either side he'll he'll come after
me after he's going and then it'll be
all good yeah good idea yeah I think
it's a good idea yeah yeah probably no
no no
where was the entrance to this I know is
at the top of this I think it was wasn't
it bridging between these two different
things wasn't it am I crazy Thank You
yogi please tell me if you come to
Canada in a French countries love you
well thank you very much I don't think
I'm going to Canada anytime soon
but if I ever do I will definitely let
people know that I'm going to Canada I
like Canada got nothing against Canada
nothing I have no idea where I'm going
could sworn it was around here wasn't it
the bridge it was bridging these two
mountains together wasn't it well maybe
I'm just going out of my mind which is
very likely I've got a lot of very
strange Bigfoot related venereal
diseases that I don't want to talk about
and I don't want to discuss in a public
forum this is I've been out here a long
time and very lonely so you know things
get weird when you ah ha here we go I
can finally stop talking all right cool
so what I'm gonna do yet is I'm gonna
lay a trap on one side cover it cover it
put some meat on it jump over it go to
the other side and then suddenly I've
got both of these covered and then I'm
in the middle of the bridge and he can't
get nothing and I can just run the other
way and jump over the other one to try
to escape him right makes sense no come
on come on
oh you gotta be joking me is this not
good enough for you
really there we go god damn it okay sure
meat there no trap it put that there
okay now I've got both cover if he comes
from one way I've got him there if he
comes from another way I've got him here
he can't sneak up on me cuz I'm on a
bridge so I've got a number guys number
oh I can't even see both of the icons oh
yeah Oh your numbers been got buddy oh
oh I'm so unbelievably smart
I am beyond intelligent something about
my brain is just on a completely other
level from everywhere else no one else
can even compare to the magnitude of
thought that my brain can [ __ ] out he's
gonna get gone he's gonna get got and
then he's gonna get get and then I'm
gonna take those sweet succulent twits
II would cease oh and I'm gonna rub them
all over my nip knobs well you can't
stop me because you'll be oops oh sorry
went off a little prematurely there got
too excited anyway whoo ha ha boy anyway
it's cold up on this bridge so maybe
that maybe this guy should hurry up turn
off my light maybe I might help Biggi
funny funny big big big big footy foot
be big big foot foot of the big big for
it 40 big man big 40 foot foot bigfooty
foot foot foot man biggie biggie for the
big man Fuli big me on 40 big man 40
foot big big 40 40 40 big man big foot
ha I spilled my drink don't come down on
now don't go now big foot don't go now I
spilled my drink it's not that bad
Bigfoot footie big man big 40min
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] whoa
what the [ __ ] hey hey my god
I'd rip my back for one second let me
jump over ah what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what but they teabagging my
corpse
what the hell happened what happened
what happened what happened what
happened what happened hey it'd be legit
Deepa oh good we're here but what what
the hell he like dough so weird he just
appeared on the bridge that's that's
unlogical that stitch him unpossible
ditz
how did he do that that's just not know
you can oh okay alright that see that
that's where I have a problem
oh listen Bigfoot you are an [ __ ]
and I hate you and I'm gonna shoot you a
van okay
I don't know
oh look Bigfoot tracks I can follow him
never mind he's gone now
that's impossible right right guys
that's that should be that should be
very impossible that I feel like I feel
like it's both unfair and impossible
huh okay let's just close up shop here
because obviously that didn't work let's
take some medicine take this very
suppository like medicine can't even see
yep that is very suppository ask shove
it up okay we're good I guess I thought
I had him I thought my genius level was
too high for this world yeah Here I am
Here I am
I just don't get why didn't he go for
the trap I don't get that oh I found the
mystics tool I found the mystic stones
I guess I'll play a trap arrow why not I
don't know okay here's the mystic stones
right next to the mystic bones I'm gonna
I guess I'll put a camera here maybe I
don't know yeah I don't even know what
to do I probably need to help with this
but I don't even know what to do cuz
that didn't make any safe he's okay see
this okay he's okay well I can't get
dere okay so there's he's that's there I
mean I could look at the camera the
camera 1 camera 2 looking right at it
we're gonna right at it right there
point it right at it it seems important
right so that should be good right
probably not maybe he's like enticed to
go towards ones that are watched by a
camera to forget mechanic reasons I
don't know how logical a be I'm trying
not to fall in the same crevasse I did
before okay yep damage no I just want
the sweet succulent Tootsie's I just
want the sweet succulent Tootsie would
cease that's all I want that's all I
want
carrot oh no not from cam throat no
nothing okay
don't break my ankles I can't help but
break my ankles my ankles are all that's
getting broke my ankles are the only
thing that's been borked my ankles are
there they're just plain old broken all
right
I'm uh yeah oh I thought I was gonna
okay I'm gonna set up and set up fire
real quick I'm gonna set up a fire right
there I'm gonna set up my tent let's set
it right
right there okay I'm in my tent tons
closed I'm any or apparently this is me
in the tent I guess whatever it's fine
did not close enough to the so not tear
it up tent right that good
dere and real feel is good okay good
okay so I'm gonna look up something real
quick I'm gonna look up some oh and just
see check the freaking cake I know I'm
near the cave but it's too dangerous I
could fall I could fall and damage my my
my tuchus I could hurt my tokus real
blade I gonna hurt my tuchus in it just
you know I don't don't want to risk it
you know what I mean oh I thought no no
no but I'm loved
my tent I don't owe my tent my dad
where's Wheaton's my sweet dent okay I'm
just gonna go back to looking and hope I
die I guess so hard and it's just it's a
lot and it just makes me feel like
nobody cares makes me feel like
everything's against me you know it just
feels like everyone's trying to kill me
and that's not fair that's not fair I
think it's not fair uh hey God I'll be
right I'm not come here I'm not not gone
anywhere I'm just hang on okay geez
what's second I got a hair ago
okay okay that's not right what the [ __ ]
what that's not right
hang on one second no that's why is it
doing that
there's money for a new tent that's real
nice but hang on I'm that's not right
what the hell
there we go hang on I'm trying to look
up stuff and fix stuff and do things at
the same time just a god
huh some sweet music while I work on
this and hopefully I die
[Music]
Oh
okay there we go
now I've got that working a little
better
there we go okay now I've got that and
I've got a guide up here that basically
echoes exactly what I've been saying it
um basically this guy he will show up
every once in a while he'll show up
every once in a while but only in
specific areas every one so whenever I
go into a new area see when I was here
he didn't attack me none after the first
attack and my goddamn tent
yeah my tent gotten thank you very much
but it's not that if the tent was gotten
it's the tent was you know there it's
not my fault it's not my fault not my
fault at all
I got it
you can't hear me what know you can hear
me maybe I don't know lag yeah whatever
I got it
hang on just you wait wait I got it okay
all right there we go everything should
be up and running whoa where
hello
I heard him just as soon as I spawned in
I mean I'm gonna die
I expect to die any minute now Rosie
he's being a real prick right now oh no
he hit my oh that's what it was he hit
my he finally hit the other the trap
there ah ah okay
wait does that mean I can go back and
get that trap because that would be good
because I saw it on the ground there
maybe I just need to go pick it up again
maybe yeah oh is that Oh cuz that would
mean that the traps can be used
unlimited number of times ah that's good
to know that's good to know I'm gonna go
get that trap cuz I want it back and
then that also means that I need to go
get the other trap again yeah okay
alright okay now I got it now I got it
now I'm getting it now I've got it now
I'm getting it now I've got it now get
it now I'm gonna get it I got it I'll
get it okay
is there a leg no I'm not CNA dropped
frames it must be over on YouTube side
if there's anything on the encoding
going wrong over there because I'm
uploading hot and heavy with full full
girth of the bandwidth uh I almost fell
what I'm finding
alright it'll be
is it all that must be just on that must
be just on youtubes end is it good yeah
well let me know if it gets good if it's
bad then now I don't even know what to
do
I'm sorry
I know I'm phrasing I know I'm phrasing
I know but maybe I won't be yeah can I
use it I can I can totally use it again
it just doesn't show up on my map ah
well that's handy dandy god yeah every
time yeah if you're having trouble
watching the stream just reload the page
apparently god damn it
it better not load me back up with to
health because if it does I'm gonna be
real pissed
oh here
really wait what it's gonna load me here
that's so weird
wait by it why all the way back here
hang on I'm getting my I got my trap
again wait what
that's so weird why would you dump me
back here and if that's the case then
Bigfoot is gonna barrel down on me real
soon which I'm not ready for but now
that I kind of got an idea of what I'm
doing here Oh yep there is there she
blows come on
you want some flare oh why oh he's up on
the bridge wait I just saw him on the
bridge oh [ __ ] he's a-comin but he's so
far away wait what if I okay
I'm makin I'm laying down a couple cuz
he's coming all right
whoa there is where is it where well
what the [ __ ] no no no no no no no yes
no what what is going on
does it make any sense I don't get it I
don't get it he wants my tootsies I want
his cutsies
I wanted his cutsies why why do what
does he want my tootsies listen woman
Tutsis boy I wanted to tease Thank You
Philippa all right I'm headed I'm headed
back trying to there's some hunting
cabins up north of here let me see if I
can find it again yeah it's it's near
the base but I think if I if I put
something down right where I am here
that'll be an area that I'm probably not
going to return to look
why don't God why why it's completely
illogical the amount of damage you take
from fall damage it's totally
inconsistent all right putting that
there that's gonna be there I'm gonna
watch it like a hawk just hammer it up
right here there we go okay so I'm
watching that one Dalbey go
go for the but I don't know if that's
good advice when it comes down to
Bigfoot but I'm gonna try my best just
to make sure that he doesn't go from my
butt
cuz I'm pretty sure that of the between
the two of us mine is much more
succulent than his William likes feet I
cannot confirm or deny whether that is
or is not true I have no recollection
one way or another and I feel I'm gonna
use my I'm going to just use I'm gonna
plead the fifth on that one where is it
I know I'm close to one this is the one
that was struggling to find before
some about cryptids Mothman I don't know
about Mothman I've never really looked
up much about Mothman to be perfectly
honest she'll be right around here
somewhere
get them footsies I'm trying look does
he's being real protective of his tits
boink ah [ __ ] god damn it
dammit it's gone
well
what happened
movement
Oh get it my tortures oh he's a he's all
he's a probably pretty pissed huh he's
probably pretty pissed but you know
maybe he deserved it maybe he deserved
it the stream keeps freezing uh I'm
literally on my end I've got zero
dropped frames my bitrate has been
perfectly strong so if you're having
issues to strive refreshing I think it's
on youtubes end there it is there it is
okay can I go up a god damn ledge
alright fairway oh good another trap
more bullet lots more bullets to okay if
he comes my way I'm gonna flare them cuz
I don't want to deal with that I'm gonna
try to exclusively keep them at a
distance okay I think up here would
probably another good place to put down
a trap I wish I could have gotten that
Fox but I can't so whatever it's all
good
we love you mark also love you well
that's too much love I can't handle all
that love No
bye-bye this Boosh
okay so I'm gonna go I'm gonna collect
the other one I think it's just a game
of attrition right I just got to keep
peppering him as much as I can in
between the times that I can trap him
and run away and if I get more flares
and they do really scare him away then
that's good then I can shoot him while
he's running away while he's running
towards me all of the above
well where well he's a common where I
don't see him OOP there he is come on
okay another hit it can't let me go this
flare what oh yeah yeah yeah running a
big baby huh
you big baby huh all right and your
noggin right in your noggin
oh oh oh did you fall down you fell down
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he's coming again I need
to reload my rifle and my flare gun oh
boy flare gun flare gun flare gun flare
gun please hurry hurry hurry hurry
hope there we go oh I got your number
now oh [ __ ] helps the fight you actually
hit him come on
oh he's so fast what the [ __ ] don't so
fast was he coming again
oh yeah is oh yeah is oh reload reload
no no no no not that it's not the rifle
the flare the flare the flare the flare
the flange or the flange of the fire how
should the beardy where am i what him
wow he wants my bow Hangul ago lows he
does he doesn't need you want some bad
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna thank my lucky
stars but also curse my inability to
reload my goddamn flare not my bong
hyung Giga who's not my bongos of gong
goes
don't die thank you great advice if ever
I heard good advice that is the goodest
advice that ever did cross my mind all
right so I'm gonna pick up my old trap
here little a date let that let it
though here we go okay it's point their
trap
oh that trap is broked okay so sometimes
they don't break sometimes they break I
guess what I'm going to take my camera
can I take my camera there we go thank
you
some of the boys you may need to help a
bobbin wave yeah I might do that if I
can't get him this time which I may but
I may not i might summon the boys the
good ol boys the good boys get him got
to get good merck employer
I don't know Mirko Flores but me I can't
get more good than I already am because
I am already at a level so far beyond
anything you've ever seen or heard of in
terms of goodness how do you get to the
markiplier is this like a how many licks
does it take question because honestly
nobody really knows ok so that's their
will you ever finish layers of fear
maybe I don't know kind of forgot about
the game forget about a lot of games I
make a lot of big promises I'm gonna
play game then I completely forget about
it that's usually how it goes it's not
out of maliciousness it's just out of me
having too many things on my mind
couldn't send just four dollars so
here's the rest
oh thank you thank you very much but no
need for that press f to pay respects
well you're so far delayed on that one
cuz or early you might be early because
the Yeti hasn't died yet but he's at
Ghana
he's a gonna I'm gonna claim those
Tutsis I'm gonna claim them for my own
I'll be mark you about the great Conda
thank you
I will maybe I don't know honestly who
knows anything anymore I'm gonna go out
of here I'm gonna lay another trap with
some food
put another camera near it I'm just
trying to get far enough away that it
doesn't count me in the same area as
before whatever that means here's a big
clearing as a work
see just wants a piece of the market
move yeah who doesn't
what can I really blame him for seems
about right
all right yeah one there with camera
Darrin Blanco
okay so that's watching that and see how
the camera and the other ones doing
three still there
five two three and two okay at three and
two got it
let's see
love your beds big ooh
well hope we got movement bo3 yeah get
it oh you stupid oh you stupid
oh my torture Oh
again again with this [ __ ] Oh keys are
coming ok so we use a common to me but
that's ok because I am gonna lay down
some real intelligent traps right here
come at me bro ever come at me you think
that you won't get got true late ok
question is which way is he coming from
also the question is is he actually
coming all the way over here
maybe not
maybe not maybe not he just loves me I
know that who doesn't okay apparently
huh whatever you do trust your but I've
never trust anything more than I trust
my own but I'd like to think there are
other people who think similarly
well I know there's just some crazy
doubters out there don't know what
they're talking about you're gonna watch
it like me huh I guess he's not okay so
he's not coming over here whatever oh
yeah that's not good
okay campfire quick thank you well now
he might be coming to me he sees his
campfire I want to try to get him on
just a normal trap right here I know if
it's gonna work why do you hate Mormons
who said I hate Mormons
I hate Mormons what have I got against
Mormons
and I don't see anything can I say out
of your boyfriend Ryan no
and shadows weird try harder I took
enough from the peanut gallery I'm doing
my damnedest here and I'm fine I'm doing
just fine thank you very much
huh please say if you support autism
awareness of course I do why wouldn't I
oh boy were you at work come on come on
hurry back for you buddy I heard you
where you at we're good yeah yeah I got
you yeah yeah yeah and get get one of
what I cleared oh he's running yeah yeah
yeah
Oh little [ __ ] baby Oh little [ __ ]
baby all right
he may be coming back for another pass
but I don't plan to be here when he does
okay I've actually almost got him oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] where oh [ __ ]
now boink
[ __ ] come on there's a sensitivity
change in between like when he's um I
can't lay here goddamn it of course I
can
nice nice there's a sensitivity change
for some reason okay you coming back
it's getting close
scream stream keeps freezing cuz it's
cold and I don't know about that we
hunting or surviving both we're both and
we're both in it up oh no god damn it I
thought it was farther ahead what the
[ __ ] I hit my own that god damn it oh
you [ __ ] [ __ ] piece of shitty how the
Frick it was farther it was dead ahead
of me I swear I'm not an idiot I'm not
an idiot well I love your videos been a
fan for years thank you good whatever
whoa Oh what oh that was that yeah
Oh stupid idiot stupid idiots to talk
not a guard how could I be so dumb again
oh I'm a fool all right so he's coming
this way I've only got one trap left so
I just can't hit it myself
I don't have any medicine I only got a
few sticks I'm gonna go inside my house
I'm a pray that I don't die
and I have this tent thought I had but I
didn't have a tent okay can you get me
in here can it get me in here cuz I can
only survive one more
I can't even survive another hit that oh
medicine yes take that yes okay I can
now survive another hit alright so I've
got one trap left that one's broken
that's not there there's another hunting
cabin where's that there's another
hunting cabin just a little west of here
that might have another trap and that
might be my best bet towards staying
alive and this one I've got 2 more
flares I'm gonna take this with me not
step on it let's go to that let's go to
that other hunting cabin see if we can
make it up everyone every right we got
incoming
there you get hit yeah oh you got hit Oh
stupid idiot are you going
oh yeah he's vanished how did you vanish
like that ah [ __ ]
okay I didn't even have to flare him he
just went well that's good he's almost
dead okay so I need to get one more trap
I can go to this hunting cabin or the
hunting Tower but also I can hit him
with a flare and take a few potshots so
hopefully hmm hopefully that'll work if
that do work that that will work
it should be just just around here
probably dead ahead of this locale I
don't know why I missed it before mark
do you suck toes
I don't know William I cannot confirm
nor deny his suck ability on Tootsie
would cease that I cannot confirm or
deny there we go there's the other one
get the toots to say hey the toots the
toots the twos there is there's medicine
two medicines got it where is he
I heard him oh I can't I move where is
he
he's around here I got to get to an
opening
where's yet who's yet come on go come on
log where's ya where's e come where's a
freaking opening it's just all dents
foot boat there is it's all dents forced
where are you where are you I heard that
where are you mom where are you huh
you chicken huh oh yeah you chicken
ain't you oh you chicken huh you too
much of a [ __ ] baby to finish this
fight huh huh huh I'm right here I'm
right here baby
I'm right here it's just you and me you
and me buddy
you mean the freezin cold there's a
stick give me a stick
he wants about YouTube channel Oh No Oh
No
well I got this I know I got this don't
worry I know I got this I know I know I
got this
I'm gonna make a campfire because that's
probably gonna draw him in I'll lay this
down I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to get him with this but I just want it
there just to make me feel better okay
you're so disappointed her not not yet
you're not
you just you wait cuz you wait it's it's
disappointment is a common
who can't step on my trap I almost
stepped on my trap what
and if they say about big feet big old
honker
I don't have any food left so I can't
exactly exactly do anything about it
I think it might be because this area
I've already encountered him in so I'm
gonna I'm gonna go to a different area
I'm gonna go across the lake down to the
south
kind of like the southeastern area I
don't think I've encountered him there
yet
thank you demon J thank you
let me get it hua hua am I saying that
right
hooah hooah hooah hooah
I'll do it I do it wah wah wah
right you can make an animation of me
don't make it up the loo
don't do that that's that'd be a cursed
animation it would never leave your
computer but if anyone wants to make an
animation of me you're more than welcome
to I'm always happy to see animations of
that sort of stuff and I'm honored that
you would but also if you want to make
animations of more worthwhile subjects
feel free to do that to call in an
airstrike you know I don't know if we
need to call Danger Close on this one
just yet I think that there's still a
chance that you know can take care of
this mono e mono mono e footy but uh you
know I'll let you know when I'm ready
for that I'm way you know you're the
true Yeti you'll never kill me you know
okay well you're pretty close to death
here not gonna lie very close very very
very close to be perfectly honest
where's chica I don't know
okay I don't think I don't think I've
been out here and I think this is gonna
be as good a place as I need to try to
face off yeah and the sun's just coming
up this looks pretty good I like the
sound of this oh yeah this looks like a
good place I'm gonna lay this trap it's
on Oh
the blood-red dawn Oh bring it on buddy
Oh bring it on maybe he's not coming to
me because I don't have any more meat on
me anymore maybe change oh maybe it's
not coming to me because my pants are
full of bees instead of beavers I was
just trying to hide shorten I hear
something shakin get him a dude
I don't like this I like this he won't
go in the water trap and shoot market
blur he won't
yeah well oh well that's gotta be here
somewhere
come on
too bad Bigfoot can't fall ass first
into the trap
yeah I want his feet to be intact with
the ass I couldn't care less about I
need to find like another meat I I think
that's what I got to do I got to go find
take this with me I'm gonna go find a
carcass that's gonna be like he's need
like a raccoon or something
now I'm so close I'm so close but he's
probably gonna be cautious don't get got
by the slender Yeti and that would be
terrifying
now it's turned into a hunting hunting
game a real hunting in need to find me a
deer a raccoon or a fox or anything
really how cold is it out there
very cold very cold
what heard that
I'm here in animals but I'm not seeing
animals yeah one second change something
I just need one deer one raccoon one Fox
transducing interplay dead I don't know
if stripping naked here is a good idea
but I could I could but whoa whoa whoa
honk there you go oh yeah whoa wait
where you going huh you can't run you
can't run you can't run you can't run
you can try to run but you can't run
some coming for you coming for you baby
yeah oh what's that no no no don't
reload the rifle reload the flare gun
okay all right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah stop hitting
trees stop injuries yeah point Gary oh
okay this is this is the one this is the
one this is the fun and done this is the
run and done this is the one done run
and done and get you mama get you was he
coming back you're gonna come back you
better where'd you go if he's coming
back I need to put this down it's the
only thing I have left
yeah he's coming back okay where you at
buddy where you at come here right
towards me come on give me some yeah I
see you oh I see you I missed you come
on come right at me right at me right at
me fall over oh oh I got him good oh I
got him good there oh I got him good
oh [ __ ] I got him well what's happening
Oh
hey whoa I guess what an anti climactic
way to end that but yeah I got him yeah
I got him good I got him good okay that
was super fun that was really like as
far as like comparing that to the last
one that was really well made that was
shockingly well made honestly and truly
that was very very well made
I am surprised by it like I didn't think
I would be but I'm kind of surprised by
it just because it you know it's it's uh
it comes from that like the original
rake it just seemed like the rake was
gonna be this really silly one but it
turned out really nice it turned out
really really nice and I like that I
like that a lot I think that's really
cool
okay so with that I think we're gonna
wrap it up here thank you everybody so
much that has been watching with me
thank you everybody there's been
cheering me on
thank you everybody that's put up with
any of the the stream problems that
there were but we did it we killed the
Yeti and if you guys want to see me kill
the Yeti with other people friends of
mine in a collab setting then let me
know about that as well thank you
everybody so much for watching take care
of yourself take care of each other
thank you everybody that became a member
of the channel thank you everybody the
game super chat and hope you guys have a
wonderful wonderful evening thank you so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye bye
bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]